tic économie la lutte contre le piratage
via internet s'organise
un comité a été installée aujourd'hui au
ministère des finances
les oeuvres littéraires mais aussi vous
ne savez le disque et le film sont
directement menacés par la possibilité
de faire des copies gratuitement une
idée choc a été évoquée aujourd'hui
privés les pirates de connexion internet
abdelah mostefa pierre-yves de unique le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
où joue autour de la table trois
ministres des fournisseurs d'accès
internet des représentants d'artistes ou
des producteurs au chevet d'une
industrie du disque malades avec en
ligne de mire les internautes qui ont
pris pour habitude de télécharger de la
musique gratuitement une époque je crois
que les gens avaient pris l'habitude le
samedi soir 2 heures du matin de rouler
à 200 km/heure et bourré bon ils ont
changé de l'habitude non alors tous là
tout l'espoir est encore là pour changer
les habitudes
le projet prévoit notamment de dissuader
le pirate par des messages
d'avertissement sur son écran ou de
fermer carrément son accès internet
après condamnation par un juge ensemble
de mesures jugées inefficaces parce
pirates
c'est un peu comme une course à
l'armement sert qu'on va trouver d
encodage et puis de l'autre côté il ya
toujours des pirates qu'ils vont trouver
à décoder mon avis c'est peut-être pour
impressionner un peu il y aura peut-être
quelques retombées aussi ils arriveront
peut-être à choper quelques adresses
mais c'est mon avis beaucoup de vent
pour rien quoi de chartes actuellement
l'étude prévoit aussi le développement
des sites de musique payante pour
l'instant pas très attractif
ces derniers mois en france les maisons
de disques ont suivi l'exemple américain
et se sont lancés dans des actions en
justice contre des internautes
au grand dam des associations de
consommateurs le fait de choisir une
trentaine ou une quarantaine de
personnes au hasard et de les lyncher un
peu en place publique alors que c'est
une pratique qui est exercée par des
millions de personnes
ce n'est pas très responsable selon nous
pour protéger la création les
associations de consommateurs opterait
plus pour une taxe prélevée sur les
abonnements internet est reversée aux
artistes
en attendant la solution chaque jour en
france ils sont plusieurs millions à
télécharger des morceaux de musique
gratuitement